you've got this
thesis or theory that
things like the lightning network or
taro
tarot will end up actually serving as
some sort of tailwind similar to maybe
cloud computing coming out of the 2008
global financial crisis first let's
start with like how do you view
lightning and tarot um and then why do
you think that they could serve as this
kind of tail when coming as bear market
so when we're looking at the space of um
of startups when we're looking at the
startup ecosystem we really want to
understand the dynamics that exist
around it to allow companies to thrive
and to really build large enterprise to
have a cultural impact and so ahead of
stillmark even launching what was
important the trigger event for
stillmark to launch as a bitcoin focus
fund was the um was the advancement of
segwit on bitcoin core and as you know
and probably most of your audience knows
that one of the ramifications of segwit
was that we could have this much more
robust lightning network bitcoin's
payment network grow on top of bitcoin
and so stillmark launched right after we
saw that segwit would gain adoption and
integration with
you know first explorer apps now the
same opportunity i think exists with
tarot so tarot is a new protocol
introduced by lightning labs
developed innovated by lalu otherwise
known as rose beef and what tarot does
is it allows for assets digital assets
to be traded on the lightning network so
peer-to-peer and what i'm most excited
about is seeing digital dollars on
lightning network and i think it's been
we've all been waiting to see
tether on lightning or tethered um with
the capability to be traded instantly
and nearly for free and now
by the end of this year i believe i
expect that that will be possible via
tarot
now this sort of links to some of the
adoption activity that we saw in 2021
right where we saw lightning network
help introduce bitcoin in emerging
markets and what really captured the
headlines of course in 2021 was el
salvador adopting bitcoin
all of that economic activity happened
on top of lightning network and so it
was a chance to do two really critical
things first it tested lightning network
at scale could lightning network work
when it wasn't just you know a bunch of
bitcoiners sending um when it wasn't
just speaking tech to tech when real
world people that weren't thinking about
bitcoin 24 7 were using it and the
answer was a resounding yes it worked
beautifully at scale the second
opportunity that we had from el
salvador's launch of bitcoin was to
actually get feedback through adoption
through real world adoption and so some
of that feedback was of course that
lightning network was a really valuable
tool especially for people that were
underbanked
but beyond that what we heard was that
bitcoin's volatility right now is hard
to handle so if you're making four
hundred dollars a month if your expenses
range between three hundred and ninety
dollars a month and four hundred and ten
to handle bitcoins volatility is really
difficult it's hard to keep your family
safe and well resourced and so what
tarot does is it responds to that
it allows you to use lightning network
to use bitcoin really um while not being
exposed to bitcoin's volatility and that
makes sense for a lot of lower
socioeconomic status populations talk to
me more about the lightning network and
kind of bringing bitcoin to all these uh
emerging markets i think that the
lightning network is a very unique story
uh in that one it didn't receive tons
and tons of hype because it didn't raise
you know venture capital uh there is no
kind of native token to it so there
wasn't a token sale or anything like
that uh it feels like it's continued to
grow organically under the radar how
important is that uh as kind of a key
way to make sure that the right people
are building on it and the right people
are adopting it that are going to be
here for the long term
well here's what you can do when you
don't have a token right you can
actually respond and get clear signal
from users so you can respond to true
user feedback when there's a token of
course the activity that you see from
users is is it's very noisy so a lot of
users when they're participating in a
token driven ecosystem are there to
speculate on the token and because
lightning doesn't have that when it
launches in a new market or
is integrated in a new app we can really
see from that user base the value that
they get from the protocol from the
technology and with that then we can
rapidly innovate and that's what you're
seeing so that's exactly what happened
with tara we saw this really beautiful
adoption to infrastructure development
feedback loop so you introduce the new
infrastructure in this case lightning
network to a user group they adopt it
you can watch their
behavior and engagement metrics from
that you can discern feedback and then
that drives the next cycle of
development and innovation in the
infrastructure side so that's tara is
really a beautiful example of that
now in terms of who should be building
on lightning pomp
2021 was amazing to see this because
there was really a sort of shift in
terms of the diversity of who was
building
so while in earlier cycles we had
bitcoiners building and a lot of these
folks are just
so brilliant they're really almost like
bitcoin native thinker somehow
in 2021 though the tool the dev tools
and the environment was more mature and
so we were able to see people that were
not religiously bitcoin or were not
building because it was bitcoin but
we're building something within their
space of expertise that could be
benefited or advanced by bitcoin and by
lightning and so that was a shift we saw
last year that i think will continue to
drive the space forward in 2022